except you are alive. And everybody, welcome to another holistic health. Our remember if you have
questions that you want to submit, you could go to holistichealthour.com. You could also find a
link at my product, our product line disease and page and our cutters clinic page. Also remember
everyone that if you don't get your question answered, we have well over a thousand blog posts
that you could get to. So if you go to cuttersklink.com, search in the search bar, we either have a page
or a blog post. Pretty much anything you could think of. And I highly recommend that people
get on our courses. I'm going to talk about that because it's first question that came in. So our
first question that came in, I believe you could check your questions in too. I'll try to keep an eye on that.
Okay, so first question that came in, any suggestions for reducing a glider? Naturally, for someone
who is hyperthyroid as well as reverse hypothyroidism, I'm not taking any medication for this condition.
So hyperthyroid is what's called Graves' disease. And that is an autoimmune condition. So you have
antibodies that have developed with autoimmune diseases when you develop antibodies. Your immune
system makes antibodies against your old tissue. And then you have destruction of that tissue and with
Graves' disease or hyperthyroidism. You have the rapid destruction of the tissue that spills out T3.
So normally your thyroid gland secretes thyroid hormone in the form of mainly T4. So you have T3
and T4. 95% of the thyroid hormone released by the thyroid gland is T4. That is not in the active
form. T3 is the active form. So it releases only about 5% in the active form. T4 is then converted
to T3 gradually over time throughout the day in the gut and in the liver so that you don't get this
spike. You need this nice balance of T3 core mold function in your body. So when a person
notices hyperthyroid symptoms they'll notice like kind of like kind of like ants crawling under their
skin. They'll have maybe a increase in heart palpitations that have a very that very kind of
increased heart palpitations. They'll feel you know just uneasy long-term issues with
Graves' disease are bulging eyes. Graves' disease can be very serious. So you want to make sure you get
that checked. If someone called and they had acute Graves' disease symptoms they went and got
checked in there. T3 was elevated. I don't think you should pull around with it. I think you should
go get medication for it. If it's relatively under control, if you've had a history of Graves' disease
but it's now under control your labs are relatively within normal limits you can do things about it.
Even if you're going to go get medication to decrease thyroid function still you need to dig into
one of the triggers that cause it. So with every autoimmune disease you'll find triggers that
stimulate more destruction of that organ. So with the thyroid whether you have poshimotos which
poshimotos can actually express as a hyperthyroid at different times but it's typically expressed as
a hypothyroid or if you have Graves' disease or if you have any other autoimmune disease meaning you
have antibodies to other self tissue you want to make sure that you're finding out what your
triggers are. So I go into triggers in detail on our chronic disease and autoimmune course.
I don't mean to push you to that. However I probably have 50 videos in that course explaining
these things. So it would be very helpful to spend 50 bucks and doing that course and start
working your way through there to find those triggers because that can greatly help a person with
any autoimmune disease to calm things down. So the problem with an autoimmune disease is you're
getting self-destruction of that tissue which you have antibodies against and the common mistake
that I see people make is that they're maybe going to a practitioner that they're told that they
might have Lyme disease or they're told that they have empty bar virus or they're told that they have
sort of chronic infection and then they're treating that person with antivirals, antibacterial,
natural things that they think well you can't hurt anybody with you know giving them garlic or
giving them a cadetia or giving them something like that a natural anti-infective agent but that's
as far from the truth as you can get you could hurt somebody quite badly. If you have antibodies to
self tissue will this use Graves disease or Hashimoto's that's your thyroid gland as an example.
If you have antibodies to your thyroid gland anything you do that is going to stimulate an immune
reaction it's going to cause further destruction of that which you have antibodies against your thyroid
gland in this case. When your immune system is stimulated you're going to kill that which you have
antibodies against first so that's the benefit of having circulated antibodies against different
diseases. I have circulated antibodies you know against certain virus and I'm exposed to that virus
again in my immune system is stimulated because of it's because of that exposure I will kill that which
I have antibodies against which will be that virus but if you have self antibodies as well you will
destroy that self tissue so you when you have self antibodies when you have a diagnosis of auto
immune disease and I'll tell you most people don't know that they do so they might mistake that they
have product disease they might think that well my problem is really that I have live disease or my
problem is really that I have empty bar or something like that but because it showed up on the scanner
because my practitioner tested me for this and that showed up positive while you may have that
if you also have self antibodies and you're doing things that will stimulate an immune system
in the idea that you're trying to kill that pathogen you will be destroyed self tissue
really really important um I just got a blood test back from somebody and they're showing
antibodies to myelin cheese cells that's neurological antibodies to myelin cheese cells your
myelin cheese cells are what cover your motor neurons and when you have destruction of myelin
cheese cells I mean that is a dem myelin 80 disease that's MS so every time that person
stimulates an immune system to kill my disease or say they've been going to different
practitioners to try to do that they're actually causing more harm than good they're destroying
self tissue they're progressing their their autoimmune disease and in this case you're you're causing
a progression of MS unknown because nobody around the test so you've got to run some tests to find out
what's going on many times when people have an autoimmune disease again there like I said they may be
treating the comorbidity of some other infection and they're taking immune stimulators you also run
the risk of developing antibodies to other tissues so over time it's not uncommon that a person starts with
graves disease or Hashimoto's disease and now they have lupus or now they have rheumatoid arthritis
or now they have antibodies to neural tissue um so running the antibody tests are can be extremely
beneficial to know what you need to try to protect um that's just getting a diagnosis then you
want to find run some different tests to get to find out what are your triggers you can have triggers
that are environmental triggers from chemicals and toxins and poisons in the environment you can
have triggers from food sensitivities so food antibodies so how do you like I said you can't stimulate
your immune system you have to be very careful not to stimulate your immune system if you have
self antibodies antibodies to self tissue but if you're eating something that you have antibodies against
let's use glutinous as an example let's say you have glianed antibodies to different glianed
peptides and you're eating gluten on a daily basis you're firing it in a beautiful spot every time
you eat that so you're going to have self tissue destruction every time you eat gluten
that's a that's a major issue so that's a trigger so you might not even have stomach issues it might
not be at all but you're causing self tissue destruction that would you have antibodies against
whether it be the thyroid or the milage cells every time you eat that so if you know you have
antibodies to self tissue aka you know you have an autoimmune disease you have to start digging
in to find those triggers you could do different lab tests different antibody tests against chemicals
different antibody test against foods antibody test against environmental things so find out what
those triggers are and you have to put out your Sherlock Holmes hat what I tell everybody it's
start looking for what I do this it does make me feel worse so that's how you would treat that's
how you really have to treat an autoimmune disease there isn't like a secret supplement for
treating an autoimmune disease you have to cloud out the immune system I guess the secret supplement
but for autoimmune disease is to make sure the wrong supplements that step that will work
oh next question who is zeolite work is there anyone who shouldn't use zeolite so zeolite fall
into the category of keylators so a key later is something that you absorb across your gut membrane
so if you're taking it orally you're absorbing that product and it's basically searching out
grabbing onto things and pulling things out of your body so the companies that sell these keylators
say things like well everybody's got heavy metals everybody's got toxins so everybody should be
taking a key later on a daily basis the problem with that is that that's it may be true that
everybody's got toxins and everybody has heavy metals but here's two caveats on taking keylators
number one is your your the process of keylation out of the tissues is that you're grabbing stuff out
of the tissues or out of the cells and bringing it back through the lip system into the blood
street it's carried through the bloodstream through your liver and then your liver has to grab toxins
out of the blood and put them through what's called phase one phase two and phase three detoxification
pathways in phase three it puts it into the bile and then it's the bile travels down to the gallbladder
that's what I call phase four and from the gallbladder it has to be secreted into the duodenum
that's the first part of the small intestine then it travels through the small intestine and you want
to make sure that your intestinal transiting time is good that you're not reabsorbing those
so you'll reabsorb toxins that your liver does all this work through these different phases
beginning into the gallbladder your gallbladder does all this work to get into the into the intestinal
that if you're a intestinal tract is slowly to your constipated which I call phase six detoxification
then you have a greater risk of a reabsorby that or if you have leaky gut issues so if you have any
intestinal permeability issues you can reabsorb those toxins that's what I call phase five so phase five
is getting it through the gut phase six is getting it into the toilet so if you're you have to start with
phase six so I explain this in detail in my book the six the seven phases of detox so phase six is
really the input getting it into the toilet phase five is making sure you're not reabsorbing it
because you have a damage gut wall so I don't think you should be doing zeolites until you heal the gut
and then you make sure that you're using binders in the gut so technically a binder
zeolite can act like a binder as well but zeolite is absorbed so it acts like a key later
but technically a binder will mainly stay in the gut to hold on to things in the gut so you don't
reabsorb them so making sure that you have a healthy gut so you're not reabsorbing things
making sure you're binding things so that you're not reabsorbing them making them going backwards again
going to the gallbladder how's your gallbladder functioning so if your gallbladder is slungish and it's not
functioning well then making sure you're cleaning out the gallbladder you're flushing it in different
ways there's different gallbladder flushes that one could do so we're talking about detoxification pathways
here so really you have to work backwards from phase six to phase five to phase four three two one and
then you do phase zero which is pulling stuff out of the tissue so shouldn't how does zeolite work
it's mainly a key later should anybody not be taking zeolite yeah anybody who has not dealt with
the other phases of detoxification why are people that say I go every three days yeah that's kind
of it I have a model that every three days okay well you go business do it any sort of detoxification
you need to get your ballman movements in proper alignment you eat corn today you should see it in
your ball move it the next morning that should be your test still transit time you should be feeling
like you're getting everything cleaned out on a daily basis super super important you got got issues
you got inflammation issues going back to doing a Syrex 10 panel looking for food sensitivities if
you have inflammation of the gut because you got a ton of food sensitivities that you have a
dealt with you know that you have damage cut border then you could do a Syrex array two and
reacts to look for gut barrier issues if you want to you know you've got barrier issues already you
should have no business doing zeolite or do it any sort of key later you need to heal the gut first
and then working that way backwards so I said there's two caveats to use it a key later what is that
is what I just explained that all your detox pathways are open and doing well I've worked on healing my
God I have daily bowel movements really healthy I know that I've knocked up three absorbing things I'm
taking a binder you know away from food to help grab out the things in the God I feel like I got
that all under control now I want to use zeolite well there's one other caveat to using a key later
so I I have labeled key laders into categories of mild moderate and in strong key laders
so a mild key later would be like clorella mild key later would be like modified citrus pectin
a moderate key later I have a blog post on it so go look at our blog post on key laders and you'll
see that but zeolite would fall into a moderate to a strong key later and you have to be careful
with moderate to strong key laders if you have metal in your mouth if you have mercury fillings
you can look at your mouth you have silver fillings and you really shouldn't be using heavy key laders
because you can pull those and you could just be making yourself more toxic so you have to be careful
with that there's that's a gray area around that so that would be my only other caveat to using
zeolite or any heavy key laders is is do you have a metal in your tissue or do you have any
implanted devices that could make you worse so I would stick to more moderate to more milder key laders
remember every you know that I would agree with the truth that probably everybody has heavy
metals everybody has toxins it does it mean that you should always be trying to get rid of them
the truth is you could do a heavy metal chelation your whole life and you're always going to have
toxins it just is what it is I don't really think that you're ever ever going to not have toxins
in your body I just don't take that the possibility um so that shouldn't be our purpose is to oh I
have to get rid of all the toxins in my body that's really my purpose of life that really shouldn't
be our purpose of life our purpose is to be as healthy as possible and to to make sure that our
rate of detoxification exceeds the rate of our toxicification that's all so we want to be working
on our detox pathways so that that they're open and they're healthy our liver is healthy that's one
of the most important thing that's really your your biggest stumbling block with detoxification with
cellular detoxification is having a healthy liver so things that we do to abuse our liver abuses are
really has some limiting factors that our rate of detoxification that's key factor
okay next question can you talk about treatment for pan and pandas so pan and pandas is inflammation
and damage to the brain many times after a strap infection many times after antibiotic use
different types of infection that can affect the brain I get to refer you to a video on my website
there's a blog post let me look at that real quick because I think the blog post is called
neuro inflammation yeah so it's called neuro inflammation and microglial primate go to our website
cuttersclinic.com go to neuro inflammation and you are all inflammation one word and microglial
primate just type in neuro they'll start to see it in the little search bar and I have about a 30-minute
video that goes over there's many different causes to microglial primate so you're
you have different cells in your brain you have your neurons that's what everybody knows about
your your neurons carry information and I mentioned the myelin cheat cells earlier well your myelin
cheat cells surround some of those neurons and that's what makes that speed of conductivity so when
you have damage to those myelin cheat cells then it slows that conductivity and we end up having
motor issues of all sorts of problems but there's another type of cell in your brain called glial cells
and those are separated in different types of glial cells glial is actually
lactic or glue because that's what they thought there was when they first discovered it oh that's just
the glue that kind of holds the neurons together well that's not true just like anything there's no wasted
things in your body glial cells have very distinct functions there's different types of glial cells
and the important one about neuro inflammation has to do with the type of glial cells called microglial
cells microglial cells are your immune function in the brain and they can get damaged they can get
damaged from live disease they can get damaged from strep they can get damaged from anything that
can cross the blood brain barrier let's just say that anything that can cross the blood brain barrier can
damage microglial cells your blood brain barriers made up of a different type of glial cells called
astrocyte and if you're dealing with a child under about three years old they don't have their
astrocytes are not wrapping their arterial system in the brain so they basically do not have a
blood brain barrier so with a child things can get cross the blood brain barrier because it's not
there with an adult things get across the blood brain barrier because some things will pass and
things will damage the blood brain barrier so we can have things that damage the blood brain barrier
even even traumas traumas are big to damage the blood brain barrier and big in damaging
microglial cells so anything that gets across the blood brain barrier like a toxin
that's the bad thing about the injections that are recommended for childhoods and for different
diseases because they contain chemicals that are nanoparticles so they contain nano aluminum and
nano aluminum is oh well that's not so harmful because it's really smoke let's actually more
harmful because it's in a nano form because it's easily and readily crosses the blood brain barrier
in it easily and readily damages the microglial cells so microglial cells get damaged and that's what
they're in what's called a prime condition that's hyper inflammatory I could go on for about an hour
of this but I'm going to refer you to that video because that will really help explain
what's going on with any neural inflammation whether it's from and we give it a pand or pandas or
whether it's you know from Lyme disease whether it's from chemo-induced neurotoxicity and we call it
chemo-brain whether it's from what you know some chemical toxicity or whether it's from post-compulsive
disorders it's all the same you're dealing with microglial primate so there's really two levels of
danger when you talk about brain inflammation you can get microglial primate which can be bad enough
as it is could cause all sorts of dysfunction and you're going to have the dysfunction in where in the
brain that is happening so if you have more microglial primate in the prefrontal cortex that's this
part of the brain that's your executive function of the brain then you're going to have dysfunction
in memory and understanding and you know executive function you're not going to have cognitive
disorders if it's in the frontal motor cortex which is a little farther back in the brain
then you can have motor issues and you know some tremor issues and motor conductivity issues
and muscle-physiculation issues if it's in the front alone then you're going to have more sensory
issues so you're going to have pain that is in my lefty today and now just that doesn't hurt but
it's my right ankle is hurting I can't feel your out and there's nothing well with my lefty or
my right ankle and it could travel around because the inflammation of the microglial primate is in
that part of the brain in the front alone where that sensory input comes back in so if it's in the
temporal lobe you're going to have hearing issues if it's in balance issues and the
stimuler issues if it's in the cerebellum you're definitely going to have the stimuler issues
balance issues if it's in the back of the brain you could have vision issues so it depends on where
that is taking place. Pans and pandas is the same thing if it's in the midbrain you could have all
sorts of autonomic issues so this this damage could take place anywhere in the brain so it could give
a collection of symptoms based upon where that damage exists. I said there's really two levels of
damage that is caused from neural inflammation one is the microglial primate which I said is bad
enough but the second one is even worse that's when we end up developing antibodies to neural tissue
so there is a test for that you can do Cyrex array 7x so you can see if you have antibodies to
any neural tissue I said tested somebody in the day and they have a neural antibodies to myelin
cheese cells that's just one thing that that tests tests for well now you know you're going to
destruction a myelin cheese cells every time you stimulate an immune system reaction for anything
that's a you even get a cold in your immune system optics you're going to have more destruction of
those myelin cheese cells you're going to have more demyelination taking place. Again that could be
anywhere where that is in the brain it's going to be on myelin cheese cells not every cell not every
neuron is myelinated but all your motor neurons are going to be myelinated and you're going to
definitely have motor neuron issues so the danger to that is when I already stated if I have
antibodies to neural tissue every time I stimulate an immune system reaction for anything
it's going to get worse and one of the chief errors in care from a natural perspective is doctors
will say well it's from this infection so it only makes sense to treat that infection we need to give
herbals and things that are going to stimulate an immune system to kill that infection that's a really
one thing to do so I again you'll find a lot more information on the autoimmune course on that
it's pretty cheap to do that I recommend spend the 50 bucks and start watching some of those videos
and work your way through that course there's a lot on there that I add stuff on there literally weekly
so even if you're on module 4 go back to the first three modules because I probably added a bunch
stuff so every time I'm learning new stuff I've put it on that course anything that has to
afford to be a disease so I'll make a video about it or something like that I'll put it on that course
so dealing with pans and pans is dealing with inflammation of the brain it could be just
microglial primate that is the cause of that person's symptoms and that would be bad enough or you could
have neuro antibodies that have been created and you can test for that can't test for microglial primate
it's mainly just um side-to-side symptoms that person is happy and still dealing with it you still
have to deal with triggers so you're super important but in that video I explained okay so we have more
questions than somebody did ask a question or not so I'm going to get to that one
just wondering if you can correct a rectile dysfunction I am unable to perform long enough buried in
a course to finish okay so yes a rectile dysfunction has to do with a nitric oxide issue is it
correctable so suddenly I treated I don't I don't really treat that but I do treat endothelial
dysfunction issue so it's really on the same course of care so endothelial dysfunction so your endothelium
is the single layer light of your blood vessels they're epithelial cells we call them endothelial cells
in the bloodstream and underneath the endothelial cells you have blood vessels and you have smooth
muscle tissue and both of them are sensitive to nitric oxide it's called E and OS endothelial
nitric oxide synthase you actually have receptors in the muscles and receptors in the blood vessels
as well and you have to stimulate with that's a form of nitric oxide E and OS to stimulate to
contract which increases the blood flow so it's going to contract the blood vessels it's going to
squish together the endothelial cells it's going to make a smaller aluminum for the blood to flow
which increases blood flow the speed of blood flow and from a blood pressure perspective it's
increasing blood pressure for someone who has increased high levels of blood pressure so they have
you know they go to the doctor they have high blood pressure you want to use nitric oxide
to relax those smooth muscles so nitric oxide works to relax those muscles
absence of nitric oxide increases those that muscle contraction it increases blood flow
so with erectile dysfunction you need nitric oxide to help with the constriction of blood flow
to that tissue so that's how you treat that it's not our specialty but that can be
and always is an issue with nitric oxide that affects the purple pill that's exactly what it does
the danger of that is that it does affect your heart so the danger of using the purple pill for
erectile dysfunction is that it does affect your heart and it is going to affect your blood pressure
so you have to be very careful with the use of that so somebody has a history of hard issues
history of blood pressure issues typically it's not recommended you're the doctor's step to
strive that it's really easy to get but you've got to be really careful of that
nitric oxide has you have to be careful with nitric oxide as well if you have a
history of cancer so a history of cancer you do not want to be using nitric oxide
of supplementation it's very common to use nitric oxide with bodybuilders as well
it can help with the workout fatigue it can help with other workout issues with bodybuilding
if you have a history of cancer you don't want to do that the reason is is nitric oxide the other
thing that nitric oxide does which is actually good for the heart is it increases what's called
vascular endothelial growth factor you may have heard of that is the VEDGE-F vascular endothelial growth
factor which is good if you have heart issues you want the heart to to be stimulated to
gladiobusels but it's not good if you have cancer so especially if you have a not
will keep you but if you have a hard cancer like a tumor type cancer
of VEDGE-F vascular endothelial growth factor stimulation will lay down and do vessels so it
will actually be able to feed the cancer and give it the ability to continue to grow so many
drugs and nutritional therapies for cancer patients are to block VEDGE-F so you will not use
nitric oxide with anybody who has a history of cancer so a lot of things that you would do for
heart disease or maybe other homo-vidities like discussed you would not do for cancer so
you're aware of that too that's question what is the best multiple vitamin well there's a lot of
multiple vitamins on the market your key things that you should look at with with vitamins themselves
is how you know the quality how I use those are the quality it's kind of pretty fancy label and it
looks that I said the drug has said it's a great supplement who says so understand there's a difference
in supplements between synthetic portions of supplements I do believe that there's a use for those
of add a whole food supplement so the difference in that is a whole food supplement is made
just basically from the food itself and so like a like a greens drink you know would be a whole food
supplement there's not a whole lot of whole food multiple on the market we do have one we actually
have a private label there's a free data but it is a whole food supplement it's really the only
whole food supplement that we have as far as like a multivitamin besides the different like greens
first products that are out there so a lot of our patients will use greens first it comes in capsules
and that comes in a powder that you can mix as you know a smoothie or something like that so those
are always the best the whole food product is always the best as far as a multiple goals
all the other supplements that are out there you have to be careful careful with as a multiple
because most of them are synthetic and especially the synthetic bees and some of the other synthetic
vitamins you don't absorb well your body doesn't use well so you have to be careful with that so
I'm not a big fan of just finding a multiple and taking a multiple thinking that you've solved your
problems but also because they're not tailored to what you have going on whenever I just said that
people with cancer have to be careful of things that they be somebody with just part disease and
they don't have a history of cancer somebody with cancer should not be taking a multiple that has
copper most multiples out there because they're using the synthetic supplements they don't care
about how their minerals are key-rated so I'll talk about that in just a second so it's really
improperly key-rated minerals which are garbage it can actually be harmful for you
maybe have iodide in it which I got big fan of iodide because the issue with thyroid issues iodide
is made cause of Hashimoto's and Graves disease and most of them have a very poor source of
folate as folic acid and no human beads should consume folic acid folic acid is a synthetic folate
and it has been hypothesized that folic acid the synthetic folate is what has caused
defects in a gene called the MTHRG and that leads to issues with that person's ability to even process
natural folate that should get in your foods and that is an issue in our society so
there's a lot of garbage supplements out there that you nobody should be taking so many times when
people come in and they're taking the supplement and it's like sorry you might have we just throw
this away this is just this is not good for you to give to your human or a dog or anything just
they're not good for anybody to consume and then the so would you look at a supplement you know
your key things that you look at are if I could think you look at the folic acid is it folate as
methyl tetrahydrofolate L that's it's MTHL tetrahydrofolate well then that's a good folate but again
it gets more technical because somebody with cancer shouldn't be taking that so is the B12
cyanochomolomy nobody should be taking that throw it away is it methylchomolomy well a cancer patient
shouldn't be taking that is it a denticelchomolomy that hydroxychomolomy yeah that's good for
the chomolomy you know that they cared about that supplement is are the minerals keylated correctly
what's the calcium is it calcium carbonate if there's calcium car if there's any of these are
red flags for me oh it's calcium carbonate they didn't care about how what they put in that supplement
then so I understand any supplement paint let's that sell supplements we can make a lot of money
selling supplements that's make a multiple well what should we do let's put the best stuff in there
oh that's too expensive let's just put this other joke in there we can make a whole lot more
okay let's do that I'm sorry but that's exactly what takes place in a lot of these companies a lot
of the supplement companies have been purchased by drug companies and they don't necessarily have
your best interest in money so I can look at a backup a supplement bottle to tell you whether you
should take it or not by looking at these key things doesn't have folic acid just throw it away is
the calcium calcium carbonate throw the thing away is the b12 cyanokabolomy throw the thing away
if you have cancer then you have to look out for other things that you should not be taking so minerals
should be keylated with a double bond to a amino acid there's only two companies in the world that
do that it's called tracks and and let me take it to the other one but they don't sell their own
supplements they sell to good supplement companies so if it says tracks or all beyond all beyond
that's the other day then you know it's a good mineral key later there if it isn't a tracks or
all beyond mineral then it's probably not double bonded to a amino acid and you shouldn't be taking it
you take calcium carbonate it's like eating limestone okay you're not supposed to eat limestone we're
not supposed to eat trace minerals that are not bonded double bond to a amino acid trace minerals
are what are in the soil soil based minerals then are taken by a plant and converted and bonded to a
double bond amino acid and then we eat plants or we eat animals that ate plants so that's how you get
your minerals you don't get your minerals by eat dirt so a lot of the minerals that are in
these poorly formulated mineral supplements and multibiterals and multivitamins are just the cheapest
soil based minerals which are not they're not good human consumption you do absorb those are the
things that damage your gut if you do absorb them they don't get into cells to function as calcium
or magnesium or selenium they end up getting deposited ligamentous insertion sites they get
deposited at joint capsules they can form degenerative arithritis and cause blood issues they can
get bonded to places that they should bond to they can damage arteries it's they're just they're
not good things so you're better off not taking any supplements you're better off getting them from
your food if you possibly can if you want to supplement that's the whole idea of a supplement you're
supplementing your diet you want to get it a whole food form as possible and you have to know a
little bit about supplements to make sure you're not getting bad boozled or divine garbage so
yeah so the best multiple I would say would be a whole food greens product something like that
or we have one that's actually labeled 3dable complete but it's a good whole food supplement but it's
not for cancellation because it does have copper it that kind of leads to this next question I don't
know if it's the same person that asked it but the question is are minerals necessary if you have a good
diet it depends so one would argue that our food even if we have a really good diet doesn't contain
the same amount of vitamins and minerals that a good diet did 100 years ago and I think you
has a valid argument I mean there's been tests done on how many how much vitamin C is in an orange
let's say versus how much it was 100 years ago there is that data on some on some of the nutrients
and it is sad story because our soils are depleted often and even if we have a good diet we may be
consuming a lot of things that damage the gut wall so we're not absorbing as many things so
technically no you should be able to get everything from your diet but there's times where our
body is under more stress like minerals are needed more in the summer because you're sweating out a
lot of minerals when you are outside and you're working outside if you're sweating a lot you're
going to need more minerals minerals are necessary for different things especially magnesium that's
probably the number one mineral efficiency and you can magnesium deficiency lead to all sorts of
different issues it's it's necessary to probably find a 700 different metabolic functions that
our body it's a it's a co-factor so it's it's something you know a good mineral is not expensive either so
so yes and no I would say if you have a really great diet maybe you don't need minerals
but a different time to stress you do so just be aware of that next question
yeah when eat spicy foods I get heartburn what does this mean and how can I get rid of it
well we had a question last week about heartburn and my answer was you do want to check if you have
a high ital hernia so remember what I said last week about what a high ital hernia is is when your
stomach can permeate up even through the hiatus the hole in your diaphragm so if hi it it permeates
into that sphincter and then you get a little bubble the superior side of that sphincter and that could
belch up acid and then you think really your problem is too much acid when you eat spicy foods you get
heartburn it's it's really most likely because you're not properly digesting them or if you have
a high ital hernia that the spice in that food can stay above that diaphragm in that part of the
stomach that is herdeated above the diaphragm and then it could will will regurgitate up your throat
and you'll have that heartburn so I would definitely check about a high ital hernia you don't go to
practitioner that that works out things like that I actually have a video on our website like I
stated last week but how to take care of your high ital hernia so I'm actually in the video teaching
by staff how to do it so go to our website cutters clinic.com search high ital hernia you'll see a
video where I'm teaching how to pull down the stomach and help with that taking digestive enzymes will
be helpful to most likely a person that has this also has a hypochloridria which is a decreased
stomach acid production so look at our that same website and search hypochloridria or HCl
hypochloridria HCl production in the stomach so hypochloridria issues lead to hypochloridria
lead to H bylora issues lead to indigestion lead to transic factor decrease the 12 deficiency lead to
just not everything so look at that so when you when you have symptoms remember your symptoms are telling
you something about something going on right so the worst thing that you could do I eat spicy foods
and it really bothers my stomach so I just take thumbs or I went got a prescription to a
vet result that's like you know I'm sorry but it's that you just shoot yourself the pain will go away
too right so don't do that this makes no sense you're treating the symptom with my covering it up
it's like saying oh my my light comes out at the car the engine light so I fixed it I put a piece of
black tape over it that's ridiculous right so I'm trying to bring it to absurdity well we do that
with our body all the time so you take a drug or something that will cover up the symptom instead of
say this is a symptom of a problem well I know the person's asking this question probably that's a
do that because that's why you're asking the question right so digging to find out why how we find out
why so let's just let to the process there then our last question for the day let's
we have some of the chat and so I know is why do so many people say to drink apple cider vinegar
well apple cider vinegar is an acid so it's a it's a moderate acid mild to moderate acid
I think the pH I don't remember the pH that the cider vinegar is not as strong as HCl
your stomach makes HCl so the stomach sells pridal cells in the stomach make piter chloroc acid
for the purpose of digesting food so HCl made it your stomach is for the purpose of digesting food
it also has a side purpose of killing any parasites that you may have adjusted so pathogens bacteria
and parasites that you have adjusted by eating your sushi or your sandwich are killed by a proper
pH in your stomach which needs to be extremely acidic so when you have a very acidic stomach
then you're going to digest food well you also need an acidic stomach in order to
treat the transit factor which is exactly how you ignore B12 so a lot of people with B12
deficiency it's yeah always going to look at hypochloridria so the reason why people would
consume apple cider vinegar is because it helps with digestion that's really the only reason
why you would take apple cider vinegar so in my blog on hypochloridria
it's best to go right to HCl I mean if you can tolerate HCl so if you start taking HCl
capsules with your food because you're trying to help your stomach digest it and wow it will
either instantly help your stomach digest it I mean instantly it will help the first day you
start taking it or you could have severe pain oh my gosh I took a couple HCl tablets with
like who did I ate something and my stomach is killing me what's wrong you quite possibly have
an ulcer so if you do have an ulcer you could back off on the HCl take a something that's a little
less acidic it's going to be a little less better for you too but it's going to be more tolerable
possibly and by using apple cider vinegar I know I haven't formulaed how to do this to start with
HCl if that's again too harsh on your stomach it's the sign that you quite possibly have
an ulcer you go back off and you try to use apple cider vinegar if that's too harsh on you too
then you have to heal the stomach so you have to heal that ulcer so then you have to do some things
to heal the ulcer that have some information about the whole of that you see the glycerized
licorice and the panel will live different things like that to heal the whole of your stomach and then
you have to work backwards and go back to apple cider vinegar tolerate that well then you start
on HCl you tolerate that well then you can start healing your gut that brings us all the way around is
the first question about detoxifying and you have to start with healing your your intestinal tract you
do that from the top out and you heal your and you don't start detoxifying you have to heal that
detoxification pathway from the bottom up which is making sure you're eliminating making sure you're
binding making sure your gallbladder is working your liver is working before you have any business
pulling stuff out of the tissues healing the stomach making sure that your HCl production is good
supporting digestive enzyme production taking some pressure off of your pancreas
so that you can heal your stomach and heal your gut so gut issues you know what's been said that
you know everything really starts in the gut that's not all together true but there's a lot of
truth to that so working on those pathways is very important okay a couple more questions came in
got a couple more minutes I'll do what I'll try to get to this all right have you treated auto
immune hepatitis uh yeah so autoimmune disease I you're you're happy to join that course I mean it's
just too complex and people are a lot of practitioners a lot of really good functional medicine practitioners
I just say this because it sounds ecotistic but they're treating it wrong so again with they're
using the immune stimulators and somebody that has an autoimmune disease they're not understanding
some basics of autoimmune disease so go to our product disease and autoimmune course if you get to
that by just going to cutters put it on the top you'll see courses click on the autoimmune product
disease and autoimmune course it's 50 bucks I mean $50 you're going to get the college education
of it and go through that and you're going to learn how to deal with autoimmune disease and how to
test for different things to find your triggers and to and to calm this all down so um in every auto
immune disease is treated very similar you have to find out what's triggering it because every time
you are triggering your immune response you haven't figured out those triggers you're getting
further destruction so whether it's your liver or your thyroid or your brain
neural tissue whatever it is make sure that you're addressing that oh another question what do
you recommend is the top healing strategies for severe rheumatoid arthritis I have tried to heal
possibly you got largely avoided wheat but dairy and tried it doesn't prescription beds without success
so I hate to sound like a broken record but rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune disorder so you
have to do you have to find those triggers there's certain autoimmune diseases that tend to be tied
to foods and the different food groups certain ones tend to be tied to different toxins rheumatoid
arthritis tends to be tied to different food groups wheat and dairy possibly with that definitely
collected for rheumatoid arthritis but again you should test for them run a Cyrex array
tend so you know what it is um rheumatoid arthritis is often also tied to heavy mental toxicity but
again you can test for that too highly recommend testing for things how do you test for these things
well you join the course so on the course you can order labs through our cutter's clinic lab store we
have zero markup so no matter what state you're in it's through Rupa's lab store it's our cutter's
clinic store through Rupa so they get a doctor in your state to sign off on your labs and you can
order labs there are some state restrictions because New York is such a stickler and so is New Jersey
but you could get a doctor in your state to sign off of your labs and you could order the labs
directly and then you can make an appointment with me to go over those so um yeah you really need to test
so it's very important to do objective testing if you really want to dig to the bottom of it
and I know sometimes the tests cost money that's why in our lab store we don't take there's no we don't
make a penny off of any of the labs done Rupa adds 7% up from the lab cost and it's a 25-dollar
charge for a doctor to sign off of your state to get it legally done you still know how you can do it
it less expensive than that so all you need to join the course and then you can make an appointment
with me and we could go over a strategy so set up a case review with me join the course and
over a strategy all specifically make some lab recommendations for you to get to the bottom of it
so I mean this Q&A is meant to help give you some idea of what we do but it's also helped to give you
some idea you know if you don't use us find a practitioner that you know educates and it's
going to dig to get to the reason why um otherwise you're like you say you know try this try that
does a different prescription guarantee your problem is that you know you're missing the prescription
or even you're missing the supplement that's just not how your body works you've got to dig to
fight out and you have to run some different tests so find a practitioner it's not us that's going to
dig and find these things out and that was what they're doing so our purpose in having this live Q&A
is to give you hope that there are people out there that understand this stuff there are
practitioners out there that care that will take the time with you um so find them if you don't use us
so we have people from all over the country we have literally people from all over the world um
mainly the United States and um you're welcome to make an appointment with me so you could do that
online too on our website cuttersprint.com you could schedule directly schedule online
fill out the form and have a consult with me and we'll go over a strategy also go to holistichealthour.com
you can see all our past holistic health hours it is indexed pretty well through AI we have that
ability to index different topics so you can find questions that you're looking for also like I said
at the beginning of this hour um go to cuttersprint.com search our blog
fitness we have a thousand blog posts also you could go from there you could go to videos.cuttersprint.com
and you'll see we have well over a thousand videos so um you know our ministry is really
to try to educate that's really my goal that's my heart if you can sense that what people to know
you know how to best take care of themselves I think the more you know the more empowered you're
going to be if you're going to give up your power to a doctor and let them do things and they're
just going to give you drugs and you're going to be more addicted to things and it's certainly not
going to solve anybody's problem so um use our services and um ask questions if we didn't get
you on this time ask questions and we'll get you on next time so go to holistichealthour.com submit
your question that's the best way to get it on all right be blessed see you next time